okay so tickets for spider-man noah home
are now on sale and with the movie
releasing worldwide in over just two
weeks we have a ton of new info on the
film that has just hit the web it's
spider monday and in this video we're
going to be breaking down all the new
trailers tv spots it's run time leaked
post credit scene and basically
everything you guys want to know about
the movie there will be some spoilers
here but i'll save things like the
league post credit scene until the end
of the video so you have time to dive
out in case you don't want to know
however i won't be able to do a doctor
strange spell on you for anything past
this point so you have been warned
without the way let's scooby-doo this
crap and get into our spider-man no way
home breakdown
okay so with tickets now on sale we
actually know a lot more about the movie
including its official run time
according to the cineworld website the
film will be 148 minutes which is two
hours and 28 minutes long this makes it
the fourth longest mcu movie and it's
going to have a lot of things going on
in its almost two and a half hour run
time we already know that the film will
pick up immediately after the events are
far from home and it'll deal with
peter's identity being out there he'll
then go to doctor strange trying to
raise everyone's memory of himself and
probably shane dawson whilst you're at
it and he'll then try and interrupt the
spell which will break open the
multiverse from this we'll spring
forward numerous villains from the
spider-man sony verse including green
goblin dr octopus sandman electro and
the lizard peter will then have to
capture them whilst getting a little
help from his friends which will lead to
one of the biggest marvel movies of all
time even though the world is dealing
with new variants that sound like
transformer villains i genuinely think
that no way home will pass the billion
mark and it's going to be super
interesting to see what pre-sale tickets
are like the movie opens on the 17th of
december in the us and the 15th in the
uk so you american kids better stop
being nice in the comments otherwise i
will find you and i will spoil you now
sony have been ramping up promotion for
the movie too and we've had a lot of tv
spots recently which i've already done
big breakdowns on however there's been
some that released after i dropped that
last video this includes the imax
promotional one which for some reason
was only released in phone format
because hey it's sony now the spot opens
with peter and mj swinging through new
york after his identity has just been
exposed in the daily bugle report by j
jonah jameson this scene is very
reminiscent of the ending of far from
home in which he and mj both swung
through the city and we know from the
trailer that his face and name will be
plastered almost across every screen in
new york we then got a much better shot
of the statue of liberty holding up the
captain america shield replica which is
where the final battle will apparently
take place at i absolutely love the idea
behind this another concept of this
being a big setting was leaked around
the time of falcon in the winter soldier
seeing it in all its glory is absolutely
incredible now you might have noticed
that there seems to be a figure standing
on the scaffolding at the bottom you can
say computer zoom and enhance all you
want but unfortunately the quality is
pretty crappy and it's difficult to make
out exactly who this is however if you
cast your mind back to some of the
apparent early leaks of toby maguire and
andrew garfield then you'll remember
that they were stood on similar
scaffolding to this and many have
theorized that this smudge on the lens
is our first look at the guy who's
always late on his rent i'm not too sure
in all honesty as i don't know if sony
would have wanted this to be the first
time that we ever saw toby maguire in
the movie but sony being sony it would
be pretty funny if we go to watch the
film and see that's the case now
according to leaks in reports toby and
andrew will come into the mcu at the
same time and they'll then come together
and use their scientific knowledge to
see what's going on and also how they
should get out of this situation peter
is of course a scientific genius i
absolutely love the idea that they'll
try and figure out what's going on first
before teaming up with tom holland we
also got a look at electro in his
engineer's jacket which was also leaked
earlier in the air according to some of
the spoilers electro will warp into the
mcu at a power station which sort of
ties into the location that he died at
during the end of amazing spider-man 2.
from what i've been told this will be
very reminiscent of how the terminator
time travels and from this point he'll
then steal an electrical engineer's
jacket before getting his harness and
arc reactor later on he'll also be
wearing tim's which is quite funny and i
can't wait to see tom holland get his
head stomped in by him now electro has
clearly just arrived into this universe
as he's talking about all the
possibilities and i absolutely love this
green and yellow jacket which is of
course a nod to the colors that he wore
in the comics other moments include
doctor strange throwing a trainer peter
and we can see this coming out of a
portal behind him this location looks
like it's in central park and we know
from the trailers that the chase scene
goes there so i'm guessing that from
this point onwards strange can't catch
him so he just throws a train at him
instead mysterio also did something
similar and far from home and poor peter
just can't seem to avoid getting a train
run on him hey how on that that one's
for the dads that one now on my last
video we also talked about how peter
parker's ty could be seen as being
completely severed when he was talking
to strange in the sanctum sanctorum this
was because when dock attacked him and
he was running low on nanotech what
remained moved from his head to his
chest and this cut the end of the tie
off in the process however eagle-eyed
viewers of you out there also correctly
pointing out that at the start of
spider-man 3 that toby's tie gets cut in
half too both him and tom are also
wearing extremely similar suits shirts
and ties too so this cutting of it could
be a call back to that huge thank you to
everyone who sent that easter egg
through and thank you for letting me
take credit for it when i own my mansion
i'll be sure to give you a job cleaning
the toilet you sucker
got you your sucker now the second tv
spot that dropped online with the
tickets is very funny and it's titled
dude because it's pretty much what peter
and ned say throughout the entire thing
tickets on sale now dude
catch
tickets on sale now dude tickets on sale
now
dude
exclusively in movie theaters apparently
apparently tickets are on sale now
tickets on sale now
now the spot opens with peter hurtling
through the mirror dimension with the
cube in his hands that he stole from
strangers sanctuary in prison this will
apparently be used to trap the villains
within the multiversal jail and once
it's powered up it'll also allow him to
send them back to their home worlds
where they'll die yay now peter grabs
this and this begins to chase across the
city i think the scene is going to be
crazy and it'll be amazing to see peter
swinging through the murder mansion
whilst the whole of new york is
collapsing around them next we catch
peter face timing ned at the top of the
queensborough bridge this moment is
clearly happening during the scene in
which we see peter and mj standing on
top of it and we later catch her doing a
balancing act trying to stay on the beam
i absolutely love this reaction to
peter's name getting out there and this
early part of the movie to me is pretty
much gonna be a metaphor for cancel
culture guys just completely freaking
out he's been exposed
and it's absolutely hilarious now i love
how ned's face can be seen on the phone
at some points before it pops up on the
screen almost like its own facetime call
the queensborough bridge is actually an
important part of the raimi verse as
it's the place where green goblin and
spider-man fought out at the end of the
2002 movie we can even catch one of the
cable cars on it that green goblin held
up and mj of course fell off it with
spider-man catching her which is
somewhat mirrored in this scene speaking
of bridges we also got more of the
bridge scene fight between darkhawk and
spider-man now when alfred molina
blabbed to the world that he was going
to be in the movie he said that it will
open with him in the river that the
character died in at the end of
spider-man 2. we'll then see a paul
appear in the hudson river before we cut
to black and catch back up with tom
holland's spider-man i've heard a lot of
conflicting things over this and been
told by some people that we just start
immediately after the events are far
from home i tend to side more with that
idea as i don't know how much sense it
makes from a narrative point of view to
introduce the multiverse when the spell
hasn't been done to then jump back to
the mcu to lead to the events of the
spell to then pull him across from the
moment that we opened the movie with
that's just me thinking about how they
would handle it but anyway that's the
two things i've heard about the opening
of the film now this fight looks great
and there's edits out there that have
pieced together enough of what we've
seen to pretty much show us the entire
scene we've also had a brand new poster
drop that's very much a variation on
what's come before but unlike the other
ones we've seen for the film spider-man
is wearing his blue and red costume that
was first seen in civil war this suit
hasn't been shown in any clips of the
film so far and it'll be interesting to
see how it's brought across it's pretty
much my favorite spidey mcu costume so
i'm hoping he starts wearing this again
for the final swing in the movie or
something now across the u.s as soon as
tickets went on sale sights immediately
went down faster than ryanairy's mom and
it even got to the point that people
were listing them for twenty five
thousand dollars on ebay when stuff like
this happens it's only to build up some
sensationalism on the internet and
though lots of people are like oh my god
25 000 you have to remember that you can
choose your own price on ebay and
something is only actually worth what
people are willing to pay for it that
being said i bought four thousand
tickets from bolden city world this
morning and will be listing him at fifty
thousand pounds of pop and you'll pay
for them because you're a sucker your
sucker now shout outs camshaft 127 on
twitter for saying this is like the nerd
equivalent of stocking up on toilet
paper and it definitely feels that way
lots of panic buying and it's going to
be interesting to see if it beats
avengers endgame's opening weekend box
office of 1.2 billion kind of feels like
nothing might ever top that again but i
think no way home will definitely be the
first film post pandemic to actually
pass the billiard mark should call it
spiderman no way are you getting tickets
hey
having that now for the next part of the
video we're going to be talking about
the leaked post credits scene for the
movie i'm not sure how legitimate this
is but just in case it's real and you
don't want the movie ruined by steven
spoilsberg then i highly recommend that
you get go on now get
anyway the post-credits scene will
apparently pick up after the events of
venom let there be carnage with eddie
brock being sat in his hotel room still
confused about what's going on according
to the leaks he'll then be transported
back to the mcu without ever even
interacting with spider-man however we
will see that some sort of symbiote will
remain behind in the universe and this
will then make its way to tom holland's
web head this is because it's seen him
on the tv and in future movies it could
then attach itself to him which will set
up the events for the next spider-man
trilogy involving the black suit now if
this turns out to be true then it's wild
to me that the whole tease at the end of
let there be carnage will pretty much
just have been done as a way to get a
bit of the symbiote into the mcu if they
go through with this then fergie clearly
just wanted the symbiote and nothing
else from those movies so he's pulled
off this big thing to get it it's gonna
be a bit weird to me if all they've done
is start a venom franchise separate from
the mcu then have him go to the mcu give
peter the symbiote to then have peter go
through the black sudok only to give it
to eddie brock of the mcu so that we can
have venom it is rumored that the third
venom film will have him fighting
against spider-man so potentially we
might get him going against garfield and
maguire but that remains to be seen i
kind of hope this isn't true as it's
gonna be pretty controversial if it is
as that post credit scene might be a bit
null and void and they probably could
have just introduced the symbiote some
other way without getting our hopes up
that's a very first world problems
response for me to have to it but yeah i
would have just liked to have seen them
all face off against one another and
then we could have set up the lethal
protector storyline from the comics in
which spider-man and venom were allies
who knows what direction things will
take but have asked about and from what
i've been told this is what's going to
happen in the movie however bear in mind
that the leaked post credits scene for
far from home said that we'd end with a
t-zone oz cup tower so these rumors
could just end up being fake like them
700 spider-man trailers you see on
youtube every day with toby and andrew
in them yes i've seen them yeah stop
sending me them they're fake that that's
why i'm not doing breakdowns on them
they're fake you're idiot
anyway thanks for thanks for all the
messages that you you guys always send
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you comment below
and let me know as a thank you you'll be
entered into a competition and we're
giving away three copies of zack
snyder's dc trilogy on the 30th of
november all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the video not the part where
i called you all idiots anyway if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of
venom let there be carnage and all the
easter eggs in it we found lots of cool
callbacks to the comics some hidden
details and it just had a lot of fun
with the movie so definitely go watch it
right after this if not then thanks for
sitting through the video i've been paul
i'll see you in the next one take care
peace